Nicki Minaj sparks romance rumors at New
York Fashion Week Heidi Klum isn't
making Drake's hotline bling' and we
have the newest name joining Dancing
with the Stars hey guys I'm back this is
the daily Dinny and I'm Courtney Tezz no
filling in for Denny as he takes over
the shy okay let's jump right in so
after Nikki spoke out on Queen Radio
saying she was humiliated by the cardi B
fight at New York Fashion Week
et caught up with Nikki at the Tommy
Lewis launch party
we'll leave it to Nikki to talk on her
own terms but the latest New York
Fashion Week sighting has everyone
buzzing Nikki posing with rumoured
boyfriend Lewis Hamilton after seeing
the two looking rather cozy together in
photos fans on Twitter started
speculating this was the new boy Nikki
hinted at when she appeared on Ellen
there's a new boy but he and I have kind
of like fell back a little bit and then
[Music]
and then there's like a newer oh there's
a newer boy so there's a newer new boy
yeah how new is this new boy like barely
new as long as the hair has been on your
mouth for a couple weeks now all right
buddy I don't what I don't have a boy
look I'm just chilling oh my god I love
the part a couple of wigs but really
there is no word on whether Lewis is the
newer new boy but Nikki says she's in no
rush to jump into a relationship she's
single she's mingling and feels more
free than ever before and we're loving
her new carefree song of Barbie dreams
remember when I used to have a crush on
special ed shoutout designer cuz he made
it out especially someone who is now off
the market is Heidi Klum but Drake might
be in his feelings about how she ignored
a text to take her out the supermodel
says Drake's message came a week too
late before she met her boyfriend Tom
Callas Heidi dished on how she dodged
the rapper's date when she stopped by
The Ellen DeGeneres Show so we played
who'd you rather he was not in there
because we didn't know him but you
didn't know anything but you picked
Joaquin and Drake person you were with
Drake the entire time who called you out
of those two my gosh Drake called you
[Applause]
basically like a week too late yeah
where he called like a week after it
aired I don't remember when it was in
and I didn't even have his number he
didn't have my number howdy howdy find
you because someone who I know knows him
and I guess he asked to have my number
and then he texted me and I was like oh
my gosh is so weird but then I you know
I never texted him back because I found
the love of my life
wait wait he texted you and you didn't
even respond right first you don't buy
your own laundry detergent now you don't
even text Drake back when he reaches out
to date you like what do you say you say
you want to go out and I'm like no but
I'm not the same did he say do you want
to go out are you embarrassed about it
yeah well you you need to text him back
and say sorry you know where's the
camera where sure Drake I'm sorry I
didn't text you back yeah yeah I mean
I'm with Heidi what do you say the girls
happily taken hopefully Drake
understands it was just bad timing and
he can now use some of that ghosted
material for his next song I hope so all
right moving on to someone who doesn't
have hard feelings about his ex Taylor
Kinney Taylor Kinney had nothing but
praise for his ex Lady Gaga as she takes
over her latest role in a star is born
of course our very own Danny direct Oh
spoke to him at the press day for his
show Chicago Fire there's a lot of buzz
coming out of tiff a star is born
Lady gaga having as an actor and someone
who has supported her how does it feel
to see her have this moment I'm only
proud I'm really proud yeah yeah I want
to see it too really well honestly
that's the kind of attitude all of us
need for exes keep it cordial and keep
it moving you guys can catch Taylor on
the new season of Chicago Fire premier
on September 26 on NBC now from
competing for a chance with Heidi to
vying for a chance to win the coveted
Mirrorball trophy we have the newest
name added to Dancing with the Stars and
you guys won't guess how young he is
please welcome Whitney in her new
partner Disney star Milo man hi
are you ready to be the youngest
competitor on the show this year okay
here's the deal honestly when I first
walked in I thought you know having a
little bit of desi experience would help
me have a little bit of rhythm but once
we started getting going it was it was
nothing like I ever imagined you know
it's it's so much more difficult than I
thought it would be and you know I'll be
dancing with her and I'll feel like I'm
doing a really good job and I look back
at the video and I just looked terrible
my low joints facts of life star Nancy
MacKinnon who will be partnered with
valve this season a source tells ET
fuller house star Juan Pablo is rumoured
to hit the dance floor and I got a
chance to talk to his co-stars at the
creative arts Emmy to see what they
think about Juan taking on the challenge
your co-star who is your husband Juan
Pablo there's a little rumor that he
might be on Dancing with the Stars and
we've seen your other co-stars do that
how awesome would that be I would be
amazing he would be a natural he's
always dancing around set he's got he's
got rhythm and he's got moves and he's
got if he wants to do it he is so super
talented you would agree with that
triple quadruple threat almost like
everything he is and he's a lovely
person give me an idea had a lot of the
cast over his house for his birthday and
his mom and dad cooked Paia
for like 40 people so I'm thinking if he
can have his parents cook paia he can
win Dancing with the Stars I mean to me
that's that's that's a 10 right you give
them a 10 you'd give him one I think you
could win I mean Candace has been on a
Jodi's been on it I'll never go on it
unless they have me on a hazmat or or
they can do it on a gurney see Bob ii
knows himself so it is a hard note for
him but we'll have to wait until
Wednesday's Good Morning America to find
out the complete list of season 27
competitors who would you guys like to
see put on their dancing shoes go ahead
and let me know in the comments I'll see
you guys later
but I promise you Vinny is coming back